en el sur de Utah Production a 800
kilómetros de Nueva Delhi raya baya
lucha contra un asesino silencioso que
azota las zonas Rurales de India este
trabajador social recorre el distrito de
banda todos los días una provincia
apartada donde su ong intenta ayudar a
las poblaciones más pobres
Nos dirigimos al pueblo de parwie me
informaron que un obrero se suicidó hace
poco Voy a visitar a su familia
raya ha asumido la tarea de llevar un
registro de los suicidios en esta región
primordialmente rural cuya población ha
vivido de la agricultura durante mucho
tiempo sin embargo debido a la falta de
tierras cada vez más hombres se han
visto obligados a irse a la ciudad a
trabajar como jornaleros obreros a
menudo en obras de construcción Se les
paga por día y no tienen ninguna
seguridad laboral Así que cuando quedan
desempleados empieza el círculo vicioso
cuando no tienen trabajo se endeudan
tienen que pedir dinero prestado para
sobre si no trabajan no pueden alimentar
a sus familias pero a menudo dependen de
usureros que les piden que devuelvan el
dinero con intereses muy altos Así que
tienen que esforzarse mucho para
encontrar un trabajo y pagar el préstamo
y algunos de ellos prefieren acabar con
su vida Antes que ver a sus familias
morir de hambre solo en esta familia
cinco hombres se han suicidado desde
2013 según raya 450 personas se han
quitado la vida desde el primero de
enero de 2020 en el distrito de banda
que tiene 1,5 millones de habitantes la
pandemia no hizo más que aumentar el
desasosiego de los jornaleros
recurrimos mucho a los periódicos
locales esto nos permite ponernos en
contacto con las familias Estos son
todos los artículos sobre suicidios en
este Distrito solamente me entristece
que un problema tan importante como este
no se ha tenido en cuenta en absoluto
por el gobierno
según las cifras publicadas por el
Ministerio del interior indio de los
jornaleros representan un cuarto de los
160.000 suicidios registrados
oficialmente en 2021 ese mismo año otro
grupo de la población se vio afectado
por una ola de suicidio sin precedentes
esta Trágica noticia nos llega desde la
ciudad de cota en rayastán tres
estudiantes se han suicidado en 48 horas
13.000 estudiantes se quitaron la vida
en 2021 en India una cifra que no ha
dejado de aumentar en los últimos cinco
años El suicidio es la primera causa de
muerte entre los jóvenes de 15 a 29 años
estas tragedias tienen muchas causas la
presión de los padres para que sus hijos
tengan éxito en sus estudios no aprobar
los exámenes de ingreso a las facultades
de ingeniería o medicina o problemas
económicos en Nueva Delhi en este campus
universitario Todavía se siente el
desconsuelo tras un suceso traumático en
septiembre vichaca de 20 años saltó
desde el tejado del Campus la estudiante
de ciencias políticas tenía dificultades
económicas una compañera de clase
intentó ayudarla pero fue en vano varias
veces me dijo que no quería seguir
viviendo intenté consolarla pero repetía
que estaba cansada de los problemas de
dinero
que nadie podía ayudar me dijo que había
empezado a buscar un trabajo a medio
tiempo para pagarse los estudios porque
de lo contrario habría tenido que dejar
la universidad porque no tenía dinero y
su familia no podía apoyar la
económicamente
la Salud Mental sigue siendo un tema
tabú en la sociedad India las
enfermedades mentales son vistas como
una debilidad y el país se ha tardado en
poner en marcha una política de
prevención del suicidio hasta 2017
suicidarse incluso era considerado un
delito asociaciones como esta organizan
talleres para concienciar a la gente y
hacerla cambiar de mentalidad
mucha gente de nuestra sociedad piensa
que las personas que deciden suicidarse
son unas cobardes este tipo de
comentarios crea un verdadero estigma
que impide que estas personas den el
primer paso y busquen ayuda
la ong se dirige a adolescentes y
adultos jóvenes en esta Facultad de
Medicina los estudiantes suelen estar
bajo presión aquella que les ponen sus
padres para que tengan buenas notas una
obsesión familiar desmesurada porque sus
hijos estudian en universidades
prestigiosas hasta el punto de llevarlos
al límite
[Música]
dos de mis compañeros de clase les
pusieron fin a sus días la competencia
en medicina es dura porque cada vez hay
más candidatos pero el número de plazas
prácticamente no ha aumentado
este descontento suele verse agravado
por la discriminación a la que se
enfrentan los jóvenes de las clases
sociales estigmatizadas
en India la casta y la identidad
religiosa Son elementos que rigen la
sociedad
existe un espacio para los sectores más
marginados de la población tienen acceso
a los mismos recursos a las mismas
ayudas
e incluso si consiguen ascender en la
escala social tendrán que esforzarse más
para demostrar que merecen estar ahí
es necesario
por primera vez a finales de 2022 el
gobierno indio puso en marcha un
programa Nacional para la prevención del
suicidio su primer objetivo es reducir
el número de suicidios en un 10% de aquí
a 2030